bonjour ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
ultimo video di questo 19 pieno di cose
intense siamo su 400 i versi come c'è la
finale di quest'anno glorioso ho voluto
provare a vedere di portare un gioco a
tema si chiama 400 ms si parla di questo
sasso
giochiamoci è una roba e da un sacco
dovevo fare questo gioco perché c'è da
un sacco di tempo non avevo mai fatto
perché l'ho visto come gioco stando però
ci sta come video la fine dell'anno si
parla di anni approfittiamone lui si
sveglia sente qualcosa che bello sembro
io la mattina quando la sera va bevuto
anche un pochettino una calamita sta
arrivando
sta arrivando una calamità o una
calamita per fermare la calamita lui
assolta ma se mi butto nell'acqua non
possono che 400 anni
io 400 anni per fermare la calamita ok
qualche volta per superare un ostacolo
deve soltanto aspettare a brevi la
sostanza però aspettare
[Musica]
l'inverno stringa medaglia veramente a
noi dovevo uscire e fare in modo che si
ghiacci oggi ma che ansia madonna
qualche volta per superare l'ostacolo
deve scalare un albero
questo lo posso fare senza metterci in
anno ok quindi o 400 anni da utilizzare
ok ho capito a questo deve crescere
fermi ufficio vent'anni 20 anni la mia
età quasi ok a posto per questo gioco
dimettersi credibile qualche volta gli
alberi sono piazzati nel posto sbagliato
che senso ha devo piantare l'albero da
un'altra parte ok plant chestnut ok
quindi pianta un albero qua poi cresce
all aperto
madonna raga che ansia
nel evidente tanto 20 ai 30 anni sulla
base 32 anni
madonna che casino va bene acqua devo
aspettare anche l'inverno che palle ma
come disse nostro gioco persone giochi
in flash c'è ma che idea [ __ ]
sono cascato di sottopeso quando ha
visitato il villaggio visto che le
persone erano cattive mi sa che devo
andare avanti con con il ghiaccio può
essere essi veri che era ghiacciato il
mondo dalle righe ma invece sta musica
rilassante cioè che figo tutto bello
[Musica]
qualche volta perso passare un ostacolo
ha bisogno di una mano
in che senso scusate amici c'è bisogno
di una mano mi date una mano c'è una
roba che aiuto è porca vacca da
aspettare madonna milan da mano questi
ho capito devo dar da mangiare ai tizi
col grano come minecraft ok quindi
adesso vado da loro e gli do il grano e
poi attendo che che mangino anni attendo
che immagino anni grano dove e poi credo
sia questo è penoso
ciao ho portato a magna così non c'è più
fame job dopo l'ordine dal river allora
beccati questo cibo che so il vostro del
libero una donna fa uno schifo piantate
di più che fastidio o bravi affiatato di
stanno a fare casette europa per bravi
quindi passa il tempo avete fatto cose
82 anni sono passati si è costruito un
pezzo di ponte come la cosa stanno
costruendo un ponte io non ho manco
capito o sono passati 94 anni sono
vecchie come quella del titanic vari che
c'è altro su questo che ho preso prima
salve come si spaventano tutti scusa ho
bisogno di una mano mi dovete far salire
prima c'era un po c'era un punto in sali
bile qua aiuto
fatemeh salini fatemeh sari
cento anni per questo ponte ottimo bene
prefiggo mi diverte
noi siamo chissà quante avventure
incredibili secondarie l'immenso e
scadere di soft ma chi che ha avuto
l'idea di falso gioco che è geniale
devo andare un po a sentimento in realtà
perché non mi ricordo dove che culo mi è
andata ancora bene con la testa
incastrata dentro un'altra roccia ma fa
niente
in fondo all'oceano proprio a beirut ci
avesse un po profilo o ma sono nei
meandri del bimbo dell'oceano una
caverna sotterranea come mycroft
stalattiti forza crescente tra un laghi
e l'altro del gioco sta aspettando un
sacco di anni occhio anno 171 madonna
perfetto aia che faceva che è affacciata
sul ghiaccio fortissimo è talmente
passano gli anni che la gavle scusi
sembra il caso di muovere la barca
mentre ci sono io salve sono una roccia
che si muove cos'è vabbè ma sono quelli
di prima che hanno colonizzato il mondo
cento guarda che sono passati 208 anni e
occhio e quan casinò siamo a metà più o
meno io vaschetti in cloud steelhead
giorni sand stava avvicinandosi alla
fine del suo viaggio
ma
faccio un vulcano lui la madonna dove
entra nel vulcano dopo klein bar evocano
andare d'isola dove vado
dentro
alla calamità il vulcano quindi io l'ho
blocco
è il vulcano la calamità quindi o blocco
il vulcano in modo tale da non presento
blow clava per space to wait
quindi ho bloccato la lama è tutto
salvato tutti è giusto no fermi eccolo
ce l'ho fatta no era giusto ci crede
sono fenomeni tanta mamma mia ogni tanto
festa aveva l'intelligenza 2013 winter
inverno con l'aereo che figlio e sono
ancora lì però come niente ero ancora lì
dai volevo andare in giro volevo andare
alle posto fuori il casino che è figo oa
mangerie l'irs signori che sarà gioco
dell'anno oggi al 2019
domani sarà 2020 ma ogni anno che passa
voi sappiate che siete vivi soul è
unicamente grazie a una roccia che si è
fatta un buco del culo così meraviglioso
ringraziate la roccia
mettete un mi piace al video se stimate
la roccia io lo metto un bacino
buon anno a tutti iscrivetevi al canale
facciate un bel commento e noi come
sempre dopo che avete schiacciato la
campanella che è molto importante e
civile al prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]